welcome back to glamour unfiltered
hosted by me josh smith and today
we are joined by internet sensation
turned actress turned beauty mogul
turned
just queen of everything basically it's
red
so how are you doing babe i'm good i'm
well i mean i feel like um a lot's been
happening but it's all really exciting
things and
i mean this is the best time to kind of
be focusing on everything i want to do
so
yeah it's so incredible i mean you have
had
the year of all years i'm just going to
hit you with some facts
you have 4.8 billion likes i can't
that's more people in like china
you have 75.4 million fans
how much has your life changed over the
last year
i mean so much it's so wild to me to
even think about i mean i was
literally in college you know at the end
of 2019
and then moved to la and um
and just kind of started chasing my
dreams fully and it was just
a really exciting a time for me to kind
of be able to branch out and do so many
things that i've always
loved and dreamt of doing and i mean i
kind of grew up just in the
entertainment world dancing and
always wanting to perform for my family
and friends so you know everything that
i'm doing now is just a branch off of
everything that i ever wanted to do
what's been maybe the biggest
pinch yourself moment over the last year
when you've been like
oh my god i actually can't believe this
is actually happening right now and the
fact that you're seeing these numbers
that you just go up and up and up and up
and up
what's that what's been like the biggest
moment you took a step back and you're
like
wtf what's actually going on i mean i
feel like
definitely doing the movie i just shot
like that was a really
big pinch me moment because that's been
a dream of mine to be an actress forever
um well to be really you know called one
now especially now that i've
started my own film it's kind of just
really insane to be able to say that
even
um but growing up i was always in acting
classes and
and um watching movies and pretending i
was the characters so even just being
able to
you know be on screen is just incredible
to me that i can say that
going into acting what has been maybe
some things that you
have you've been nervous about the
reception that might get i think for me
it's something that i've been passionate
about my entire life so i feel like it
wasn't really
um that scary for me in particular to
kind of get into that
but i think for a lot of people i was i
was a little nervous about what people
would say because people don't really
know
what i did or aspired to do before i
started social media so people kind of
base
anything i do off of like oh she started
on social media
i think as well it's so tough from going
from being a relatively
normal person living your life normally
to them being thrust into the spotlight
and then everyone has an opinion right
and
social media is so empowering in so many
ways like you saying it's given you this
chance to live your dreams but equally
it comes with so much negativity
sometimes as well
what kind of negativity have you come up
against online and how have you learned
to deal with it i mean there's
definitely
been a lot of things i feel like i can
think about that i've dealt with just
with online hate and kind of
um just social media kind of drama if
you will you know just
just people that are like very
opinionated and um
and kind of just don't want people to be
happy with some things and i feel like
that kind of comes naturally with
anything in life you know
people see people's successes sometimes
and
and wish it was them which is like
totally understandable and i feel like
i've even been there in my life too
where i'm like
oh i'm so you know i wish i had this or
i wish i had what she had and then i
kind of
bring that anger out onto them which has
never been like
a fulfilling thing and i think i
realized even in my life growing up
what would you say would be some sort of
triggering things
you would see in comments that would get
to you
initially and now you learn to kind of
deal with them a lot of it has to do
with like body image
i know you know it's a really hard thing
to deal with
when you're a girl especially going
through um
you're like teens and then kind of
growing out of that i mean guys deal
with it as well there's so much around
body image that people have this
um high standard like oh you have to
look like this
to be to look great or to to look hot or
to be
cool or to be pretty like you have to
look like this and your body type has to
be like this
but i think um for me a lot of people
have been like
oh you know i love how comfortable she
is that she doesn't look like the
beauty standard and it's like kind of a
backhanded compliment sometimes because
people will
you know be like oh i'm so glad she's
confident that she doesn't look perfect
and you're like
like you know it kind of hurts sometimes
when people say that because it's like
i think everyone's perfect so why is
there some standard of like oh this body
is the ideal body like there
i feel like there's just so much that
i've thought about in the past year
that's been like you know
that doesn't really define me and there
is no standard of perfect because there
is no such thing as perfect
how has your relationship with your own
body image change
as you've gone through your life what
been some turning points in that
i'm 20 years old and i feel like my
body's always changing especially now
more than ever so i think um
it just it just really comes with me
wanting to be
my healthiest version of myself and i
think that's what at the end of the day
i think about you know i don't have to
look a certain way to be perfect or to
be healthy it's really just about my
body and
um physically and mentally and
emotionally being as healthy as i can
yeah you just touch on there which i
think is such an important point you use
your platform for the greater good as
well
what have you used for you what you most
proud of shedding a light on and
what has kind of been some turning
points in you realizing hey you had a
voice and b how to use it anytime i see
something going on
i like to really read into it before i
speak on it because
i don't want to be speaking about things
i don't really know about
or understand and i think that's a
really important thing for people to
understand as well because i think a lot
of people
you know will be like why isn't someone
speaking on this or this or this but
we don't necessarily know everything
about everything
so you have to kind of do your research
and understand exactly what you're
speaking about and then
uh doing that as you know to the best of
your ability because for you as well
there's so much
i think we're all under a massive level
of pressure right now in the context
that we're living in
but i think with social media comes so
much mental health pressure as well
what has been some sort of turning
points in your mental health
journey and your relationship with your
own mind there's this one quote that i
love and it's comparison is the thief of
joy
and i think that's so true because it's
you know when you start comparing
yourself to someone you're just asking
to really be upset about it and
understand that
you know maybe yours whatever it doesn't
look like there whatever and i think
that just is a big part of like
stealing the happiness out of you
because you're comparing yourself to
something that
you will never be because you're only
you and it's a process isn't it and you
actually do
have to work on it
um i mean i think there's so many things
i even started seeing a therapist
because i feel like that was really
helpful just to um
you know not feel so down about myself
even just self-worth i think self-worth
is the big thing that i've been working
on
the past few months even um because it's
definitely
a real struggle and it does affect you
in your daily life you know having
not very high self-worth and i think
that's something big that i want to work
on and therapy is a great way to do that
and kind of also an outlet to kind of
speak on things that are bothering you
and
um and internally even externally you
know just being able to have someone to
talk to has been a big thing for me
what do you think is the biggest lesson
you've taken away
from therapy or is there a piece of
advice you heard during therapy and
you've been like oh my god this is game
changing
i think just not letting your past
define your future and i think
not falling into the same thing that you
may have seen or known
that you know is not right and then
letting that dictate what you're going
to do in your life um and just really
directing your own path and making your
life what you want it to be
i think that's so important i think we
all need to realize that we are the
creator of our own lives right
what do you think has been like maybe
the proudest moment for you
when have you been the most proud of
yourself that's a that's a good question
i don't know i feel like
uh every day i mean i just i'm very
proud of the things i've been able to do
and even just
staying mentally healthy has been a
really big
accomplishment for me i think just going
through the changes of life and
and really staying grounded and um
remembering where i'm from and
you know how i got here and not taking
anything for granted has kind of just
been my
most proud moment is just really you
know taking every moment in
and living my life to the best i can it
seems like there's such an amazing
sisterhood
on the tiktok platform and off it as
well
how have you leaned into that sisterhood
and when has that sisterhood helped you
the most would you say
yeah i mean i think having a support
system
you know over the over the internet or
outside the internet is both equally as
important i mean having friends that you
can count on
regardless if it's physically or not is
a super important thing and luckily i've
had a great group of friends to really
support me and be there for me and
understand where i'm
going through you know and where i am
but also like family comes into that
really really big and i think having
um friends and family that can really
support you and be there for you to lean
on is a really
important factor in just keeping
yourself healthy and happy
and i think also off the back of that
like it must be so amazing to have
a friend like courtney kardashian for
instance who has literally been through
every single thing under the sun you can
go through in a public sphere
how helpful has that been for you when
you're discovering yourself in this very
public sphere and what's maybe a piece
of advice she's given you you've been
like oh my god this is like
so helpful something that she told me
was just you know make sure you're
always enjoying
what you're doing because at the end of
the day this is the life you're living
you know so make sure it's something
that you're proud of and
um and you're continuing to do the
things you love
because i think as well like what's so
amazing about the podcast view of your
mom is it's all about
that is such an incredible podcast a and
then b on top of that
it's so incredible to have this kind of
message that it's
okay to have these difficult
conversations and tricky conversations
with your parents right because that is
hard for you personally what has maybe
been some
difficult conversations you've had to
have and then once you've had them
you've been like oh my god i feel so
much better maybe what been some
conversations you've had to have
with yourself too um i mean i think
overall
conversations are sometimes difficult to
have especially when they have to do
with
you know your thoughts or feelings so
anything like that i mean
it's obviously always difficult to kind
of open up to your parents on how you're
really feeling about things or how
you're
you know understanding things but um you
know as honest as you can be is the best
way to do it because then that's when
someone can really help you and kind of
give you insight on what they think you
should do
based i feel like i'm getting some
self-help here this is like
i'm like yes i'm unique i'm special
this is great yes you are no you are and
i think that's what's kind of helped me
just get through everything is realizing
that
you know no one is ever going to be this
one standard of perfect and we're not
all just going to look the same and be
the same so i think
just recognizing that and being you know
telling yourself
i can only be the best version of who i
am what's maybe the most ridiculous
thing you've done for the like call of
beauty would you say
i will say that one time i was like very
obsessed with dimples
like i loved the way dimples looked on
people so i looked up a youtube video on
how
to get dimples and i would literally you
would take like a pin
like even something like this and then
like spin
it in your like dimple and i was like i
need it it's the prettiest thing ever
dimples are the best in the world
and i was like i don't have them so i i
need them
i can't believe you're literally getting
a whisk
into your face i literally would i was
getting pencils and pens and
markers and i was like yep i'm gonna get
dimples because i love them
being like a new gen kind of like beauty
mogul what did you set out to do and
what did you want to tackle
that was happening in the beauty
industry and create a new space i feel
like for me i'm really connected with
gen z because i am a part of it
um so i kind of get that chance to speak
for the people
that want to see certain things in
makeup and i think for me even growing
up
like i said um i i can just kind of
speak for people or almost be an
advocate for things because i am a part
of gen z and i do have an audience that
is willing to listen and
um hear me out so i think with clean
beauty products as well i mean
growing up i didn't think it was that
important um and i didn't really know
the difference or wasn't really educated
on what
that meant but now more than ever i can
really push that and you know
say clean beauty is better for your skin
and more healthy and better for the
environment and
just being vegan and cruelty free is
really important to me so being able to
be a part of jinzy and speaking on that
and having
products that are a part of that is is
really awesome
because i think as well like throughout
this whole conversation we've been
touching on this quite a lot but
it's this idea of validation isn't it
and how we value ourselves as human
beings and
sitting here in society today because i
think a lot of people get validation
from social media but then it's not real
validation is it and if you base all
your validation on that
then you're not going to have validation
in your own life have you navigated the
concept
of validation and whenever you've fallen
into some trappings of
what validation means i mean i i think
it's
that's a really tricky thing too because
it's like you know obviously when i post
i want to make
my audience happy and and really like my
content but at the same time i can't
constantly base what i'm doing off of
someone's reaction because it may not be
what makes me happy
you know so it really comes down to to
finding that middle ground in everything
you do like
you know i want to make the people
around me feel as happy as they can but
i also need to make sure i'm feeling
happy doing it as well
and that kind of just comes with making
sure you're always doing what you love
so then doing what you love can result
in the people that love that as well
it's to be happy do you feel like in
doing that you kind of got rid of some
of the pressures that society puts on
you
in some ways and what kind of pressures
have you felt like you've been put under
at different times in your life do you
think um yeah i mean i think just
in different things overall even growing
up as a dancer it's like there's always
you know comparisons and people are like
well if you're this age you should be at
this level or if you're on this team you
should be at this
you know ranking and i think that that
kind of just
falls into everyone is on their own
terms about everything and kind of going
through their lives in different stages
and no one is on the exact same path
ever um so just recognizing that and
and really finding you know
self-validation in that like i'm doing
the very best that i can
so that's all i can do sitting here with
that knowledge
if you could go back to a time in your
life and be a friend to yourself
when would you want that to be and what
would you said
to that younger you even you know when i
was younger in high school even going
through breakups and in college and
things like that
in the short time that i was at college
don't get me wrong it wasn't
very much time but um you know just
being there for me emotionally when i
needed that
and when i didn't have someone that i
felt like i was comfortable enough to
talk to about anything just really
recognizing that um if i go back to what
i value most and if i go back to the
things that i really
want to feel in life and and accomplish
in life then
at the end of the day that's what's most
important because we never know how long
we're on this earth so really getting
your priorities straight mentally
and emotionally is is a really important
thing i think as well
we will people will look at you and
think this is an overnight success
this has been amazing like this meteoric
rise but they won't see the no's or the
negative situations that happen to get
you to that place
in your life is there a no that you've
received that the time was devastating
and then actually looking back now it
was actually the most empowering thing
that ever happened
um i mean i feel like there's always
obviously like trials and things that
you go through in life that are really
difficult but i think one for me that
really stands out is
whenever i went to college i was trying
out for
um or before i had went to college so my
senior year i was trying out for the
college dance team
and i ended up not making it and then
about
four to five months later that's when i
had started
social media and tick tock and then all
of a sudden you know out of nowhere i
was
i was posting all the time and then
getting you know likes and views and
followers and then i was like
okay maybe you know what i thought would
be my life
turned into something different and now
i get to pursue all those dreams that i
initially had
without even doing what i had thought
was going to get me there
sometimes the the road you didn't think
you were going to take is the one that
you do and and you're glad that you did
and honey you just keep driving down
that road
slaying left right and center because i
think it's been amazing talking to you
today and i feel like i'm going to take
a lot away from this
but i'm going to be like self-loving
left right and center now
yes that is what this time is about